all she wanted was a hug from her mum
she used to beg the staff to allow her
to come home to her mum and just want my
mummy
in february lindsay's daughter lauren
took her own life
she was alone in a mental health
hospital
250 miles away from her home and her
family it was meant to be a temporary
move when she died she had been there
for nine months
as soon as i saw her phone ring i knew i
just knew
in the weeks leading up she was very let
down she said that she could see no way
out and she was going to be
held in that hospital forever
so this is the last picture that i've
got of me and lauren while she was alive
what was she like when you when you saw
her she cried a lot
she didn't want to leave she followed me
out with a ward
clung to me so i couldn't move
lauren was autistic but was sectioned
under the mental health act after she
was diagnosed with a personality
disorder when she turned 18.
she was in what's known as an out of
area placement
sent from dorset to manchester because
of the lack of local beds
lindsey says not only was the hospital
she was sent to not suitable for
lauren's needs she wasn't even warned
about the move
i woke up to a phone call from lauren
she was hysterical crying her eyes out
and she said that some hospital
transport was on its way to pick her up
and she was being sent to manchester
so i didn't even have the opportunity
to go and say goodbye to her
some days we'd spend all day on the
phone to each other so i could calm her
down
she was scared to death
do you believe that
the fact that lauren was sent so far
away and where she was sent
contributed to her taking her out
absolutely
absolutely
the government pledged to end
inappropriate out of area mental health
placements by 2021 but it never happened
not all placements are recorded but we
know there were at least 660
inappropriate placements ongoing at the
end of last year that's more than 90
percent of all out of area moves
a placement is classed as inappropriate
when it's made because of a lack of
local beds
they cost the nhs at least 118 million
pounds last year
but these numbers don't even capture the
true scale of the problem nhs england
only published data on out of area
placements for patients who are over 18
and yet children too are being sent
hundreds of miles from home often with
devastating results
she went in hardly self-harming and she
came out and she is covered in scars
her body is like
it's like she's like the walking wounded
last year when claire's daughter imogen
needed impatient care
the only bed available was in berry near
manchester
a six and a half hour drive from their
home in kent
imogen who we've blurred here to protect
her privacy was at the time 13 years old
so i was just like i had to you know i
just kept saying i'll be back i'll be
back i'll be back i'll be back in the
morning i'll be back in the morning i
promise i'll be back in the morning
so i went back up to manchester spent
all of my savings on petrol on airbnbs i
thought she's never going to get better
if she knows i'm not here after five
months imogen was discharged in october
but claire says there was no plan in
place for her return back home and she's
now so ill she doesn't leave her room
there was no cohesion
and i feel here we are what five months
on again
and i've had to resign for my job i'm
her full-time carer i've got no respite
she's still not taking any medication
and i'm like well what was that what was
the point in that
our life has fallen apart
completely
claire's mp rosie duffield is now
pushing for a debate on the issue in
parliament
it's really become urgent we need the
health secretary to look at this and to
ring fence that mental health spending
so that it is directed towards these
services not leaked to other emergency
areas in the nhs we really need this to
be taken seriously
the government told us they missed the
target for ending these placements
because of the pandemic and said we are
investing an extra 2.3 billion per year
to transform nhs mental health services
by 2024
meaning more people will be able to
receive care as close to home as
possible but this is aimed at community
care and not in patient beds
the reality on the ground is that the
system isn't working so
even though we're how you know we have
expansion of community services
there are areas and so many areas across
the country that don't have enough
impatient beds
the royal college of psychiatrists say
the only answer is funding to replace
mental health beds that have been cut by
70
in the last 30 years
what is the risk to
patients to the mental health system as
a whole if we don't get a handle on this
sending people away miles away for their
treatment is simply unacceptable
it's devastating for their mental health
and i use the word devastating because
it is truly devastating for them and for
their families
lilies represent
hope for us
so she sent me this for lindsay memories
and pictures are now all she has left
if the government had stuck to their
plan
then we would still have lauren
and other families might still have
their children
she still hopes these placements will be
stopped even though any change comes too
late for lauren
katie barnfield sky news
you